بالنسبه للهدنه مشاهدينا تستمر هذه الهدنه
المعلنه بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع رغم تسجيل بعض الخروقات في الايام
والساعات الماضيه وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
اعلنت ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه راعيتين
الاتفاق الهدنه رصدت تحسن ملحوظا في
احترام اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار قصير
الامامد والترتيبات الانسانيه في السودان
من جهته مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بورا قال ان
الاوضاع في السودان لا تحمل نوايا او
اراده سياسيه واضحه للتوصل الى حل غير
عسكري في الوقت الراهن مضيفا ان بعض
الاطراف الخارجيه باتت تؤجج الوضع المتفجر
بالفعل في السودان اما منسق الامم المتحده
الانسانيه المقيم في السودان عبده دينك
فقال للعربيه انهم سيبلغون عن اي خرق لوقف
اطلاق النار
مراقبه الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار في
السودان ضروريه سنبلغ عن اي خرق للهدنه من
الجيش او الدعم السريع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات